Okay, you're dancing
against the truck right now.
You gotta dance
with it, girl.
God, this
is terrible.
I don't know.
It kinda feels good
on my back.
Yeah, I mean
it's actually kinda fun.
Good save, Morgan.
Abbi, do you remember that
holiday party that we thought
that we ran out of cheeseballs,
and then it turned out we had
more cheeseballs
in the back?
Yeah,
the cheeseballs.
Yeah.
I'm not gettin' married until
everyone can get married.
Why did you look at me
when you said "everyone"?
What do you mean?
What do
you mean?
You gay, man.
Oh, yeah, I am.
I'm totally
gay.
I got it now.
I got
what you mean.
♪
Abbi, do you remember
that time the chicken satays
were way underdone?
Do you remember?
I still laugh
about it.
(laughing hysterically)
(Ilana)
This bitch
is unraveling.
(Abbi)
I am well
aware.
(laughing)
What are
we laughing about?
I don't know.
♪
God, I can't believe Will
didn't go to Penn Station.
What a little bitch.
It's the most vibrant
place in the city,
and they have
really good sushi.
You know what,
I'm fine that he left.
He had a really
big penis.
How big, how big,
how big?
Like, think
earth, like think earth.
Coke can,
plantain big.
Oh, God!
♪
What are those?
Poppers.
What do they do?
They loosen
your butthole.
Why you takin'
it right now?
'Cause we're going
to a wedding.
Hello?
Abbi, this keeps
happening to you.
You're like a magnet
for elephant dongs
God, you know who had
the really big dick?
My brother, Mitchell.
Hold on, Morgan,
did you say something
about your
brother's dick?
I didn't mean to say that.
Just forget it.
Delete, delete, delete,
delete, delete, delete.
(yelling)